Les amis bienvenue au Canada
L'homme qui vient de passer c'est Clément
Bonjour !
Excellent !
On a été invité pendant une semaine au Canada par  Destination Canada
Je vous explique rapidement parce que c'est assez fou. On a un guide qu'est là avec nous et on a des activités prévues chaque jours
on va faire des trucs un peu wtf, on va faire des trucs en pleine nature.
Ça va qu'être des activités assez folles
là j'vous parle j'suis "jetlagué" pourquoi ?
on a atterri euh... il y a 2 heures
et on va déjà tout de suite maintenant partir faire une activité
t'es fatigué ?
trop fatigué
je pleure
est ce que tu penses que la taille de cette baignoire est raisonnable ?
tu peux t'asseoir dedans et ...
est ce que *rire* ?
est ce que c'est uniquement un endroit cool pour rater son ramadan ?
*rire*
Clément va me suivre avec la caméra
on va vous faire vivre ça avec nous ça va être assez ouf
et là on part pour la première activité c'est du scooter électrique
sur passe-muraille
le mec il a pas le programme                       j'ai oublié
ok je me suis complètement trompé
on va visiter le Mont Royal en scooter électrique ainsi que
les murales de Saint -Laurent
tout de suite
les amis  la première activité est sur le point de commencer j'arrive au magasin de scooters électriques
et en fait c'est un parcours on va se balader et on va checker des murales
et en fait des murales c'est des œuvres de rue et il y en a beaucoup ici à Montréal
donc ça va être une sorte de petit tour où on va aller en mâter plein
Ah bah voilà mec
le magasin est là
je m'équipe et on va mâter toutes ces oeuvres d'art ensemble
tu peux pas tester mon swag !
Ok ! On va se balader à l'aide de cet ustensile extrêmement rigolo
J'ai mis une petite caméra embarquée pour que vous puissez vivre la puissance d'un moteur électrique
2 chevaux avec moi
J'espère qu'on va tomber sur des très belles murales et puis et puis c'est ti-par !
Allez salut !
Ok mec ! Première murale.
C'est une semaine de travail pour réaliser ceci
C'est Frédéric qui vient de nous le dire. Frédéric
c'est un nouveau youtuber. C'est faux !
C'est notre GUIIIIDE !
Voilà, c'est Fred qui va nous amener  à des trucs stylés pendant ces deux premiers jours du voyage
Donc une semaine pour faire ceci !
et on dirait que ça c'est Tex qui l'a fait puisque c'est le même visage que "Les Z'Amours"
J'en vois une juste là bas. Qu'est ce que je fais ? Je m'en vais !
Ok les amis ! Nous sommes à Pains, on continue à pied pour atteindre le haut du Mont
Et en fait, on aura une vue sur le centre ville de Montréal.
Quoi de mieux quand tu arrives à Montréal q ue d'avoir une vue tout de suite très belle sur Montréal ?
Ok! On y est. On est au sommet du Mont Royal
234 mètres de haut. On a une vue sur absolument tout Montréal
Et là-bas, 100km vers là-bas, c'est les Etats-Unis !
Voilà !
Les amis on vient de terminer la balade en scooter électrique c'est très très cool
on a vu de trèèèès trèèèès  belles murales
Je suis très content des artistes
extrêmement talentueux, pas autant que le King du destin Squeezie mais quand même
On enchaîne sur la deuxième activité, dernière de cette journée
Parce que faut rappeler qu'on a attéri, quand même, à midi aujourd’hui et que là il est  17h
Et que le jetlague il te prend et *se baffe*.
Bon pour cette seconde activité, on va
lancer les haches! Des vraies haches, il y aura une cible, on aura des vraies haches *rires*
Non ce n'est pas un logo pour un salon Hipster de barbier de France
C'est parti on va filmer tout ça, ça va être drôle, on y va!
de sécurité, et comment lancer une hache. Il vient de faire un lancé au milieu de la cible, c'est parfait.
Avec son retournement magique du "c'est normal", c'était vraiment très beau!
Euhh.. On va tester, on va tester, ça va être drôle
AHAH  ! C'est dur hein !
On a fait une entaille mec! On a fait une entaille ! Un début ! *rire*
*bruit d'applaudissement*
Enorme ! C'est le plus beau jour de ma vie ! *rire*
*rire*
C'était la scène la plus convaincante de tout Hollywood
Ok on sort du sport le plus barbare du monde !
c'était fou par contre le jetlag mec, il me euh... Je sais pas toi
Je sais pas si tu remarquais mais le jet lag ça rend fatigue.
Oh nooooon
-Mais Clément revient ! On t'aime quand même Clément c'est pas grave vient !
-C'est bon c'est bon !
C'était très barbare et en fait mine de rien c'est assez sportif de lancer des haches pendant une heure
Surtout quand tu as un corps de mante religieuse
Là on rentre, on dort et mec demain, programme de malade ! A demain
Et BIM, direct début de la deuxième journée, on est déjà dehors on est déjà habillé
Qu'est ce qui se passe Lucas ? tu n'es  pas en caleçon dans ta chambre d'hôtel wtf ?
les amis aujourd'hui on commence par une activité, je crois la plus flippante de tous le séjour
C'est de la décalade. C'est à dire une descente en rappel. c'est comme l'escalade mais inversé.
Tu ne descends pas dos au vide, tu descends face au vide. Donc on va totalement se chier dessus
On est au Vieux Port, c'est une ancienne tour industrielle qui a été aménagé pour proposer cette activité
Ça va être assez ouf.  Mec en vrai, j'ai un peu peur. En vrai j'appréhende un peu
On monte ? Allez, on monte, c'est parti ! On y va !
Ok, c'est parti les amis. on va se taper 260 marches pour arriver en haut
Ça fait 60m de haut. un maximum de sport
et de calories brûlés !
Wow ! Mec !
Je me chie totalement dessus c'est incroyable
Je me suis jamais autant chier dessus
C'est vraiment pas
Intuitif au début. Tu as une corde et quand tu l'ouvres tu peux avancer
ET HOP ! Ca te stop d'un coup dès que tu la ramène à droite. C'est très étrange
Ça va super bien
Je sais pas, honnêtement je sais pas si je peux le faire
Ça va bien aller
Mec je te jure je me chie trop dessus de ouf
Ça va bien
Je te jure je me chie trop dessus. Je sais pas si je peux le faire c'est fou
Impossible que je le fasse, je te le dit je fais un blocage de ouf
Je suis trop mal
Est-ce que tu peux te dire, j'ai passé de près de faire quelques chose de très, très, très trippant
Ou je l'ai fait
Que veut tu ramener comme souvenirs ?
Je sais pas, le souvenir d’être envie
Les amis je me chie tellement dessus
Que j'envoie mon sbire avant
Pour voir si tout le matériels marche bien
Mec j'ai tellement peur c'est fou !
Je vais chialer ça me fera du bien. Je vais pleurer dans un coin tout seul là-bas.
A toute hein. Salut
Bisous !
Eh mais mec vous imaginez même pas l'effet que ça fait, c'est terrifiant
En faite c’est juste le fait de passer le gap je pense d'aller dans le vide
Qui est difficile.... Tu vois
Mais une fois que t'y est, t'y est et c'est bon
Oh putain il est chaauuud !
Chers amis Clément a réussi
C'est un très gros bonhomme. Je vais devoir le faire aussi du coup
Sinon il va me vanner pendant 2 siècles
Ok on y est.... Waw
Je suis entrain de vivre un truc de malade !
WAAW
Mec
Je suis en vie
I am alive
Waw les gens, c'était totalement incroyable
Mec cette sensation.... J'arrive plus a parler
Je ne sais plus quel est mon métier, je ne sais plus ce que je fais dans la vie
Allez Salut ! A bientôt Montréal merci !
J'ai trop bien fait de y aller de dire oui. Il m'avait prévenu en me disant que j'allais être tout content
Mec j'imaginait pas que j'allais l'être a ce point
C’est grâce a vous, que je peux vivre ça putain
Que je monte sur un truc, a je sais pas combien de mètres du sol
Pour y sauter
Et marcher a l'horizontal, ça n'a aucun sens
Dernière activité de la journée ! Avant d'aller voir Nabil Aiekillu
On ne peut pas venir a Montréal sans voir un ami youtubeur, c'est pas possible
Après tant d'adrénaline, il est tant de faire une activité un peu plus calme
Posé, un peu de pédalo sur le fleuve Saint-Laurent
C'est parti
Mec on vient de signer une décharge pour un pédalo c'est un peu violent
Et la apparemment on va mater une vidéo qui nous explique comment pédaler sur un pédalo
Fred c'est quoi ce délire ? C'est un guet-apens que tu nous fait
Ouais
Il assume totalement, c'est un mec qui fait un guet-apens le plus calmement du monde
Ok les amis
Le son est dégueulasse une fois de plus je m'excuse, on peut pas prendre le Sony alpha 7S, Pourquoi ?
Parce que Fred nous a tendu un guet-apens
En réalité on va aller dans des bateaux saute mouton, ce sont des bateaux qui sautent sur les vagues
Et ceci très, très fort. Donc on a une GoPro la à la main
Et on a une GoPro sur le casque, putain on se fait engueuler faut y aller. Damn it !
C'est chaud parce qu'on a aucunes idées de la puissance du truc
On ne sait pas ce qu'on va se prendre dans la gueule, on n'a un petit coupe vent, c'est pour ça qu'on a un style un peu nul
Mais ça permettra de pas cailler.
Donc les rapides ce sont des eaux, dans lesquelles il y a beaucoup de mouvements
C'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça les rapides. Ça remue énormément
Et du coup quand tu navigues dessus, ton bateau il prend des coups, et nous on est sur ce bateau
Ok les amis on s'approche des rapides
On les a en visuel
Y a pas mal de vagues
On est prêt a être mouillé
WTF ! On a pris une vague c'était Titanic
Jsuis trempé
Et voila vous avez tous cette chanson dans la tête c'est incroyable
Bon mec c’était fou, c'était fou putain mec. Il nous a mis des claques dans la gueule
J'avais jamais fait de saute-mouton
Bon j'en ai fait quand j'était
Ce soir on voit Nabil, et on va dans sa ville mais c'est nous qui le mettront bien
On va lui faire une surprise, on va l'emmener faire du jet ski pour aller voir les feux d'artifices
En attendant repos a l’hôtel, c'était top mec putain je suis tout secoué
En faite tu te prends vraiment la quantité d'eau
D'une douche entière de 20 minutes mais en moins de 2 secondes et bien dans le nez
Bon allez let's go
Les amis nous sommes avec. Je suis présent je suis la. Nabiil !
Nabil Aiekillu on a visité son appart, on a visité son chien
Son chien est vraiment très, très beau un Husky, attention une photo maintenant
Il a même pensé a laisser son sac là-bas pour qu'on retourne exprès
Petite astuce, petite astuce si vous voulez revoir l'appartement de quelqu'un
Oubliez votre sac chez lui ça marche à tout les coups, c'est fou
Mec on est au festival de juste pour rire, coté bouffe y a de la bouffe de partout
Et Nabil nous a pris une petite poutine spécial indien
C'est comme le poulet au beurre, curry qu'on prend en France
Mais en version poutine mec
C'est énorme, c'est délicieux
La tache en direct live, on a réservé une petite excursion pour aller voir le feu d'artifice
En scooter de mer
On va faire du Sea-Doo
Ils disent du Sea-Doo, c'est le dernier soir avec Fred
Il nous quitte demain
Je vient a peine de le connaître il s'en va déjà
Allez a tout de suite sur un scooter, Sea-Doo
C'est terminé la balade en amoureux, ça ta fait plaisir cette petite balade ?
Oui franchement c'était génial
Il a fallu que t'arrives après 7 ans de Montréal pour que je puisse faire du jet-ski
Que tu découvres qu'il y ai du jet-ski a coté de chez toi
Nan c'était vraiment cool mec, tu as une très belle ville
J'espère que les activités vous ont plu les amis, n'hésitez pas a aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu
Allez voir la chaîne d'aiekillu et de notre chaîne a nous et je vous fait plein de bisous
A très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, il est ou Clément faut dire au revoir a Clément. Clément tu dis au revoir quand même
A bientôt !